Come on, guys.
We don't wanna be late.
Do I have to go? It's the only
day I get to play games.
We're all going.
Come on.
I don't understand why we have
to go to church every Sunday.
Church is important,
Stan.
Way more important
than video games and TV.
Church is about community
and coming together --
a lot of things.
All I know is that after church,
I just feel better.
Yeah.
Me, too.
[ Indistinct conversations ]
Hey, mornin', Stephen,
Linda!
Morning, guys.
Man:
Oh, thanks, there, Randy.
You got it.
Where's Josie?
Aw, she slipped her disc
in her neck.
Poor thing
can barely move.
Aw, she's gonna miss church?
That's too bad.
Give her my best.
[ Conversations stop ]
For God so loved the world
that he gave
his only begotten son
so that whoever believed in him
should have eternal life.
This is the gospel of the Lord.
Townspeople: Praise to you,
Lord Jesus Christ.
Today's gospel talks about
what the Lord has to give us.
He did so because we could not
control our temptations.
Kind of like a priest
in a room full of naked boys.
[ Townspeople snicker ]
Okay. Okay.
Let's -- let's try and have
none of that today.
In John 3:16, the gospel tells
us how God so loved the world,
he gave to us his only son.
And a Catholic priest
raped him.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, okay.
Come -- Come on, guys.
N-Now, what greater gift
could the Lord have given to us?
Children's underwear
which priests couldn't
pull down so easily.
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Let's -- Let's try
and compose ourselves.
Let's try and just get through
this first one, okay, guys?
What does it mean that the Lord
gave us his only begotten son?
It means
if you're a cute boy
at a Catholic priest
swimming party,
you better be gettin'!
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
Oh, that was a great one,
Nelson.
Salvation
in a little boy's mouth.
I'm gonna post that one
for sure.
Who said the thing
about naked boy salad?
Oh, that was Linda!
Well, see ya next week,
everybody!
-Yeah! See ya!
-All right. Take it easy, now!
-Bye.
-That was good.
I really don't understand
the point of all that.
Yeah, well, I used
to think that about church
when I was a kid,
too.
But back then, I don't know
if church was that stupid.
Hey, don't say
things like that, Stan.
You wanna go
to [bleep] hell?